Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On the evening of Saturday, January 27, 2001, Roxana Verona drove to the small town of Etna, New Hampshire, and turned onto Trescott Road. It was a long stretch of bitumen flanked by brush, low stone walls, and tall thickets of trees on either side.
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。2001年1月27日星期六晚上，罗克珊娜·维罗纳（Roxana Verona）开车前往新罕布什尔州埃特纳（Etna）小镇，转入特雷斯科特路（Trescott Road）。这是一条长长的沥青路，两侧是灌木丛、低矮的石墙和高大茂密的树丛。
There was also roughly an inch of fresh snow on the ground. Occasionally, picturesque homes could be seen through the dense foliage, but most of the road's houses were hidden from view. Although it was only just after 6.30pm, the area was already cloaked in darkness due to the midwinter season. Roxana pulled up at a gravel driveway and turned, following the curved 50-yard driveway downhill and parking at its base. Next to the driveway was a garage and behind it was a two-story house.
地面上还有大约一英寸厚的新雪。偶尔，透过茂密的枝叶可以看到风景如画的房屋，但这条路上大多数房子都隐藏在视线之外。虽然当时刚过晚上6点30分，但由于正值隆冬，该地区早已笼罩在黑暗之中。罗克珊娜在一处碎石车道旁停下并转弯，沿着弯曲的50码长车道下坡，停在车道底部。车道旁边是一个车库，后面是一栋两层楼的房子。
Built just 16 years earlier in 1985, the property was modern and surrounded by gardens and woods, making it an ideal home for residents seeking a peaceful retreat. The couple who lived in the house were Roxana's good friends, Hoff and Susana Zantop. A warm, social pair, they had invited Roxana over for dinner. Roxanna grabbed her handbag and a salad she'd made before getting out of the car and walking to the front door. She rang the doorbell, then placed a hand on the doorknob. To her surprise, the door was unlocked. Despite being the sort of people who often hosted guests, Hoff and Susanna were also security conscious, and always locked their house up.
这处房产建于16年前的1985年，外观现代，周围环绕着花园和树林，是寻求宁静休憩之所的居民的理想家园。住在这栋房子里的夫妇是罗克珊娜的好友，霍夫（Hoff）和苏珊娜·赞托普（Susana Zantop）。他们是一对热情、善于交际的夫妇，邀请了罗克珊娜过来吃晚饭。罗克珊娜抓起手提包和她做好的沙拉，下车走向前门。她按了门铃，然后把手放在门把手上。令她惊讶的是，门没锁。尽管霍夫和苏珊娜经常招待客人，但他们也有安全意识，总是会锁好房门。
Roxana wondered if Susanna had left the door unlocked for her benefit. Susanna had mentioned that Hoff would be out at a birthday party when Roxana arrived. Perhaps Susanna had decided to take a shower and wanted Roxana to be able to let herself in. Roxana turned the doorknob and entered the house, calling out I'm in as she did so. She hung her coat and handbag up at the end of the hallway, then placed the salad on the dining room table. All of the house lights were on, but Roxana noticed how strangely quiet it was. She couldn't hear the shower running or the sound of someone bustling about getting ready. Walking into the kitchen, she found it empty.
罗克珊娜心想，苏珊娜是不是为了方便她而没锁门。苏珊娜曾提到，罗克珊娜到达时，霍夫会去参加一个生日派对。也许苏珊娜决定洗个澡，想让罗克珊娜自己进来。罗克珊娜转动门把手走进屋里，一边走一边喊道：“我进来了。”她把外套和手提包挂在走廊尽头，然后把沙拉放在餐桌上。屋里的灯都亮着，但罗克珊娜注意到屋里静得有些奇怪。她听不到淋浴的水声，也听不到有人忙碌准备的声音。走进厨房，她发现里面空无一人。
Some bread, cheese and chopped vegetables were out as though someone was midway preparing a meal, but there was no cooking aroma. Susanna, Susanna, Roxana called. There was no reply. The house felt empty. Then Roxana noticed that the study door was open and a light was on inside. She headed towards the room, which was usually a neat and tidy space, with hundreds of books lining floor-to-ceiling bookshelves and Hoff's desk with everything in place.
桌上放着一些面包、奶酪和切好的蔬菜，看起来像是有人准备饭菜到了一半，但空气中没有烹饪的香气。“苏珊娜，苏珊娜，”罗克珊娜喊道。没有人回答。房子里感觉空荡荡的。接着，罗克珊娜注意到书房的门开着，里面亮着灯。她朝那个房间走去，那通常是一个整洁有序的空间，从地板到天花板的书架上摆满了数百本书，霍夫的办公桌上一切也都井井有条。
Yet, on this occasion, it was in total disarray. Papers and photographs were strewn all over the floor and a card table was knocked over. Roxana immediately noticed that Hoff and Susanna were there too. Both lay on the floorboards, and both were covered in blood. At the house next door, Bob McCollum was celebrating his 76th birthday with his wife, his daughter and his son-in-law. Just as the group were raising their glasses in a to Toaster Bob, they heard someone pounding at the front door and a woman screaming.
然而，这一次，房间里一片狼藉。纸张和照片散落一地，一张牌桌被撞翻了。罗克珊娜立刻注意到霍夫和苏珊娜也在那里。两人都躺在地板上，身上满是鲜血。在隔壁房子里，鲍勃·麦科勒姆（Bob McCollum）正和妻子、女儿及女婿庆祝他76岁的生日。就在大家举杯祝贺鲍勃时，他们听到有人在猛敲前门，还有一名女子的尖叫声。
They found Roxana Verona outside, crying about the grisly discovery she'd just made at the Zantop residence. Bob's wife called 911, while Bob, a doctor, ran next door to see if he could help. Roxanna and Bob's daughter went with him. While Roxana hid in the Xantops kitchen waiting for police, Bob went to check on his neighbours. 55-year-old Susanna lay on her stomach near the study door. The card table that had been knocked over was resting on her calves.
他们发现罗克珊娜·维罗纳在外面，哭诉着她在赞托普家刚刚发现的可怕一幕。鲍勃的妻子拨打了911，而身为医生的鲍勃跑去隔壁看能否帮忙。罗克珊娜和鲍勃的女儿也跟着他去了。当罗克珊娜躲在赞托普家的厨房里等待警察时，鲍勃去查看他的邻居。55岁的苏珊娜脸朝下躺在书房门附近。那张被撞翻的牌桌压在她的腿肚子上。
There was a large puddle of blood pulled beneath her head, which faced away. It appeared the blood came from a large slash made across her throat. Susanna was wearing a brown and black jumper and tan corduroy trousers, which were also covered in blood. Bob McCollum checked Susanna's wrist for a pulse, but found none. Her husband, Hoff, who was 62, was a few feet away from Susanna, sprawled on his right side. His head rested on the base of a bookshelf, which was splattered with blood. Like Susanna, Hoff's clothes were blood-soaked.
她头下积了一大滩血，脸朝向另一边。看起来血是从她喉咙上的一道大伤口流出来的。苏珊娜穿着一件棕黑相间的毛衣和棕褐色灯芯绒裤子，上面也沾满了血。鲍勃·麦科勒姆检查了苏珊娜的手腕脉搏，但没有发现。她的丈夫霍夫，62岁，躺在离苏珊娜几英尺远的地方，右侧身倒地。他的头靠在书架底部，书架上溅满了血。和苏珊娜一样，霍夫的衣服也被血浸透了。
There was a cut in the left leg of his jeans, and he had been stabbed repeatedly in the chest and head. Hoff's face was white and completely drained of blood. It was clear to Bob that he too was deceased. The fate the couple had met was an extremely violent one. Spots and splatters of blood covered books, paperwork, chairs, and an oriental rug that was beneath Hoff's feet. There was also a clear clue as to the weapon used to inflict the violence. Lying on top of a bloody Birkenstock sandal that had come off Susanna's foot was a black plastic knife sheath.
他牛仔裤的左腿上有一道切口，胸部和头部被多次刺伤。霍夫的脸苍白如纸，血色全无。鲍勃很清楚他也已经去世了。这对夫妇遭遇的命运极其残忍。血点和血迹溅满了书籍、文件、椅子以及霍夫脚下的东方地毯。现场还有一个关于行凶武器的明确线索。在苏珊娜脚上掉落的一只带血的勃肯（Birkenstock）凉鞋上，放着一个黑色塑料刀鞘。
It was more than a foot long and three inches wide. A second matching sheath also lay under a nearby chair. Within several minutes, multiple police officers from Hanover Police Department had arrived at the scene. Hanover was a large town that lay four miles west of Etna, right near the border of New Hampshire and Vermont. Its biggest claim to fame was that it was home to the Ivy League University, Dartmouth College. Many residents of Etna were employed in Hanover, and despite its semi-rural appearance, Trescott Road was a popular thoroughfare for commuters between the two towns. The Hanover officers were also joined by members of the New Hampshire State Police and officers
它有一英尺多长，三英寸宽。另一个配套的刀鞘也躺在附近的一张椅子下。几分钟内，汉诺威警察局的多名警官赶到了现场。汉诺威是一个大镇，位于埃特纳以西四英里处，就在新罕布什尔州和佛蒙特州的边界附近。它最出名的地方是常春藤盟校达特茅斯学院（Dartmouth College）所在地。许多埃特纳的居民在汉诺威工作，尽管特雷斯科特路看起来半乡村化，但它是两镇之间通勤者常走的一条路。汉诺威的警官们还与新罕布什尔州州警和来自
from the Grafton County Sheriff's Department. They conducted a sweep of the Zantops home to ensure the couple's attack wasn't hiding somewhere in the residence before turning their attention to the crime scene. There was a trail of blood leading from the study out of the house. In the foyer was a partial bloody print left by a boot. Two more prints were found outside and eventually a total of five full or partial boot prints were identified. Nineteen full or partial finger and palm prints were also collected. Hoff and Susanna had both suffered numerous. knife wounds. As well as having her throat cut, Susanna had been stabbed in her head and abdomen.
格拉夫顿县治安官部门的警官们汇合。他们对赞托普家进行了搜查，以确保袭击者没有藏在住所内，随后将注意力转向了犯罪现场。有一条血迹从书房一直延伸到屋外。门厅里有一个靴子留下的部分血迹印记。在外面又发现了两个印记，最终总共确认了五个完整的或部分的靴子印记。还收集到了十九个完整或部分的手指和手掌印。霍夫和苏珊娜都遭受了多次刀伤。除了喉咙被割开外，苏珊娜的头部和腹部也被刺伤。
Hoff's injuries were mostly to his chest, including to the heart and lungs. Both of them would have died within seconds or minutes. Forensic technicians combed surfaces for hair and took samples of multiple blood droplets. Other investigators seized numerous items from the home that they hoped might offer up evidence, including a desktop computer and a laptop computer and a laptop. Judging from the scene in the kitchen, it looked as though the attack had taken place earlier that day at around lunchtime. There was a pod of homemade soup being prepared on the stove. Chopped vegetables and herbs lay nearby, along with a loaf of bread and two blocks of cheese. Interviews with the couple's loved ones would reveal they tended to follow the same
霍夫的伤主要在胸部，包括心脏和肺部。他们两人都在几秒钟或几分钟内死亡。法医技术人员在表面搜寻毛发，并提取了多处血滴样本。其他调查人员从家中查获了许多他们希望提供证据的物品，包括一台台式电脑和一台笔记本电脑。从厨房的现场来看，袭击似乎发生在当天早些时候的午餐时间左右。炉子上正煮着一锅自制汤。附近放着切好的蔬菜和香草，还有一条面包和两块奶酪。对这对夫妇亲人的采访显示，他们倾向于遵循相同的
routine each weekend. Hoff would get up early, bring his wife a cup of tea in bed, and they would sit and chat. Then Susanna would cede a household chores while listening to the radio. They had morning tea together at 11 a.m., then homemade soup at 1pm. On that particular Saturday, records would show that the couple had emailed some friends at 8.30am, and Susanna called Roxana Verona at 10.30 to invite her over for dinner. That was the last time anyone had spoken to the couple. Hoff and Susanna had both moved to the United States from Germany, but met while they were studying at California's Stanford University during the 1960s.
每个周末的例行公事。霍夫会早起，给妻子端一杯茶到床上，然后他们会坐着聊天。接着苏珊娜会一边听收音机一边做家务。他们上午11点一起喝早茶，下午1点喝自制汤。在那个特定的星期六，记录显示这对夫妇在上午8点30分给一些朋友发了电子邮件，苏珊娜在10点30分打电话给罗克珊娜·维罗纳，邀请她过来吃晚饭。那是最后一次有人与这对夫妇交谈。霍夫和苏珊娜都是从德国移居美国的，但他们在20世纪60年代在加州斯坦福大学学习时相识。
They were an intelligent couple who spoke multiple languages and were passionate about education and progressive politics. Hoff, who was six foot tall and an avid outdoorsman, earned a PhD in geology. Susanna was peteered at five feet, but described as a bundle of energy. She obtained her master's in political science before later achieving a PhD in comparative literature. The couple married in 1970, had two daughters, and later became professors at Dartmouth College. Susanna was chair of the university's German faculty, while Hoff taught geology and earth science. They were popular with the students and staff alike and made friends easily. The Xantops loved hosting dinner parties where they would debate ideas and discuss arts and culture.
他们是一对聪明的夫妇，会说多种语言，热衷于教育和进步政治。霍夫身高六英尺，是一位狂热的户外运动爱好者，获得了地质学博士学位。苏珊娜身高五英尺，但被形容为充满活力。她获得了政治学硕士学位，后来又获得了比较文学博士学位。这对夫妇于1970年结婚，育有两个女儿，后来成为达特茅斯学院的教授。苏珊娜是该校德语系主任，而霍夫教授地质学和地球科学。他们深受学生和教职员工的喜爱，很容易结交朋友。赞托普夫妇喜欢举办晚宴，在那里他们会辩论观点并讨论艺术和文化。
After their daughters grew up, they decided to leave Hanover for a more rural setting and bought the Trescott Road property in Aetna. They loved how natural light streamed in through its large windows and the way it was surrounded by nature. The fact that the house wasn't visible from the outside led investigators to suspect the couple had been killed by someone who knew them. A stranger passing by the road wouldn't see the home down below. Moreover, there was no sign of a break-in, and aside from the mess in the study, the house hadn't been ransacked or rummaged through. Hoff and Susanna owned a number of extremely valuable works of art, yet none were stolen. Hoff's wallet was missing, but nothing else. The scene didn't look like a burglary gone wrong.
女儿们长大后，他们决定离开汉诺威，去一个更乡村的环境，并在埃特纳买了特雷斯科特路的房产。他们喜欢自然光通过大窗户射入的感觉，以及它被大自然环绕的方式。房子从外面看不见这一事实，使调查人员怀疑这对夫妇是被认识他们的人杀害的。路过的陌生人看不到下面的房子。此外，没有闯入的迹象，除了书房里的混乱，房子没有被洗劫或翻找过。霍夫和苏珊娜拥有许多极其珍贵的艺术品，但一件都没有被偷。霍夫的钱包不见了，但没有其他东西丢失。现场看起来不像是一起失败的入室盗窃案。
Plus, the attack had taken place in the late morning or early afternoon in broad daylight. That seemed like an odd time for thieves to strike. Then there was also the extremely brutal nature of the murders. Stabbing was a particularly violent way to kill someone and involved up-close direct contact. Both Hoff and Susanna were victims of overkill, with some wounds made post-mortem. This suggested a personal motive and a murderer driven by rage. Everything seemed to be pointing to a targeted attack. Word of the double homicide spread like wildfire through the Dartmouth community as well as Hanover and Etna more broadly.
此外，袭击发生在深夜或午后，光天化日之下。这对小偷来说似乎是一个奇怪的作案时间。还有就是谋杀案极其残忍的性质。刺杀是一种特别暴力的杀人方式，涉及近距离的直接接触。霍夫和苏珊娜都是过度杀戮的受害者，有些伤口是在死后造成的。这表明存在个人动机，凶手是被愤怒所驱使。一切似乎都指向了一次有针对性的袭击。双重谋杀的消息像野火一样在达特茅斯社区以及更广泛的汉诺威和埃特纳传播开来。
When reporters at the college's student newspaper learned that two professors had been murdered, they published an article on their website and distributed it to all students via an email bulletin. Violent crimes were rare in this community, where many residents left their doors permanently unlocked. Fear spread, along with speculation as to who could be responsible. Some wondered if an angry student might have committed the crime. Others suspected a jealous colleague. Investigators were tight-lipped and wouldn't say if there was an ongoing risk to the community or not. More than 30 officers from multiple law enforcement agencies were assigned to the case,
当学院学生报的记者得知两名教授被谋杀时，他们在网站上发表了一篇文章，并通过电子邮件公告分发给所有学生。暴力犯罪在这个社区很少见，许多居民永久不锁门。恐惧蔓延开来，人们纷纷猜测谁可能是罪魁祸首。有些人怀疑是否是一个愤怒的学生犯下了罪行。其他人怀疑是一个嫉妒的同事。调查人员守口如瓶，不愿透露社区是否存在持续的风险。来自多个执法机构的30多名警官被分配到此案，
making it one of the largest investigations in New Hampshire. In a media conference about the killings, members of the public were asked to keep an eye out for anyone in their circle who was behaving suspiciously. That included having a particular fixation on the case, sudden absence from work, altered sleeping patterns, a change in drinking or smoking habits, or seeming nervous and irritable. During an interview with investigators several days after the murders, Hoff's teaching assistant said he could only think of one person who might want to kill the professor. That individual was another geology professor who worked on the other side of the country
使其成为新罕布什尔州最大的调查之一。在关于杀人案的媒体发布会上，公众被要求留意身边任何行为可疑的人。这包括对案件有特殊的执着、突然缺勤、睡眠模式改变、饮酒或吸烟习惯改变，或者显得紧张和易怒。在谋杀案发生几天后接受调查人员采访时，霍夫的助教说他只能想到一个人可能想杀害这位教授。那个人是另一位地质学教授，他在全国的另一端工作，
at Arizona State University. Stanley Williams was 14 years younger than Hoff Zantop, and although he was based in Arizona, he had obtained his PhD in geology at Dartmouth. His work had been overseen by Professor Dick Stoiber, who was also responsible for hiring Hoff Zantop. On the afternoon of Saturday, January 27, Hoff had been planning to drop in on Professor Stoiber's 90th birthday celebrations prior to having dinner with his wife and Roxana Verona.
在亚利桑那州立大学。斯坦利·威廉姆斯（Stanley Williams）比霍夫·赞托普小14岁，虽然他在亚利桑那州工作，但他是在达特茅斯获得的地质学博士学位。他的工作由迪克·斯托伯（Dick Stoiber）教授监督，斯托伯教授也负责聘用霍夫·赞托普。1月27日星期六下午，霍夫计划在与妻子和罗克珊娜·维罗纳共进晚餐前，顺道参加斯托伯教授的90岁生日庆典。
Stanley Williams was somewhat famous amongst the geology circles due to an incident that had taken place eight years earlier in 1993. Williams had been leading a small group of scientists, engineers and tourists to a crater by an active volcano when the volcano erupted. Nine of the 15 attendees were killed and Williams was gravely injured after a rock struck his head. He nearly died and was left with permanent brain damage. He began to have angry outbursts and suffered bouts of depression. According to Hoff Zantop's teaching assistant,
斯坦利·威廉姆斯在地质学界颇有名气，因为八年前的1993年发生过一起事件。威廉姆斯当时正带领一小群科学家、工程师和游客前往一座活火山的火山口，结果火山爆发了。15名参加者中有9人死亡，威廉姆斯在头部被岩石击中后受了重伤。他差点丧命，并留下了永久性的脑损伤。他开始出现愤怒的爆发，并患有抑郁症。据霍夫·赞托普的助教说，
Williams had been open about the fact that he wanted a job at Dartmouth, but the only one he was qualified for already belonged to Hoff. On the day of the Zantop murders, Stanley Williams had actually been in town to attend Professor Stuyber's birthday party. He had caught a flight from Arizona, then rented a white DeW sedan to get around. Hoff's teaching assistant said Williams had been in a strange mood at the party. He seemed tense and angry, before suddenly becoming friendly and celebratory,
威廉姆斯曾公开表示他想在达特茅斯找一份工作，但他有资格胜任的唯一职位已经属于霍夫了。在赞托普谋杀案发生当天，斯坦利·威廉姆斯实际上就在城里参加斯托伯教授的生日派对。他从亚利桑那州乘飞机赶来，然后租了一辆白色道奇轿车代步。霍夫的助教说，威廉姆斯在派对上的情绪很奇怪。他看起来紧张而愤怒，然后突然变得友好和喜庆，
offering the assistant some champagne straight from the bottle. It was the first lead detectives had. They tracked down the rental car Williams had used and searched it thoroughly. In the boot was a cardboard box with a reddish-brown stain that looked like blood. Several investigators wound up flying to Arizona to interview Williams and his wife. Williams admitted that he'd run into Hoff the day before the murders, but firmly denied being involved. When asked if he'd hired anyone to kill the Xantops, Williams was adamant that he hadn't. Investigators remained suspicious and took blood samples from Stanley Williams, but they couldn't find any evidence tying him to the crime.
直接从瓶子里给助教倒了一些香槟。这是侦探们掌握的第一个线索。他们追踪到了威廉姆斯使用的租赁车辆，并进行了彻底搜查。后备箱里有一个纸板箱，上面有红褐色的污渍，看起来像血。几名调查人员飞往亚利桑那州采访威廉姆斯和他的妻子。威廉姆斯承认他在谋杀案发生前一天遇到了霍夫，但坚决否认参与其中。当被问及是否雇人杀害赞托普夫妇时，威廉姆斯坚称他没有。调查人员仍然持怀疑态度，并提取了斯坦利·威廉姆斯的血样，但他们找不到任何将他与犯罪联系起来的证据。
Testing would reveal that the blood-like stain from the box in his hire car was actually the remnants of a stew. Williams had taken a pot of the stew to a friend's house and placed it in the box to prevent it staining the car's upholstery. Two weeks after he first entered investigator's sites, Stanley Williams was ruled out of the investigation. Meanwhile, in the absence of any arrests or worthwhile developments, the rumour mill went into overdrive. The Xantops' next-door neighbors told reporters that the couple had recently been counselling a troubled student. Hoff had told them that the student was a young man experiencing distress, but didn't give a name. His neighbours had warned him to be careful, as in their opinion the student sounded like he was
测试显示，他租来的车里盒子上那块像血一样的污渍实际上是炖菜的残留物。威廉姆斯带了一锅炖菜去朋友家，并把它放在盒子里以防止弄脏车的内饰。在进入调查人员视线两周后，斯坦利·威廉姆斯被排除了调查范围。与此同时，在没有任何逮捕或有价值进展的情况下，谣言四起。赞托普夫妇的邻居告诉记者，这对夫妇最近一直在为一名陷入困境的学生提供咨询。霍夫告诉他们，该学生是一名经历痛苦的年轻人，但没有透露姓名。他的邻居警告他要小心，因为在他们看来，这个学生听起来像是
suffering from paranoia. They wondered if he could be responsible for the couple's murder. Other people also talked about a student possibly being behind the crime. The day before the murders, Hoff was seen in his office engaged in a shouting match with a student. Both were speaking in Spanish at the time. The student was tracked down. It turned out that he was completing a double major in English and Spanish. He said he'd taken Hoff's Earth Sciences course sometime earlier and the two had become friends.
患有偏执狂。他们想知道他是否应对这对夫妇的谋杀负责。其他人也谈到可能是一名学生在犯罪背后。谋杀案发生前一天，有人看到霍夫在办公室里与一名学生发生争吵。当时两人都在用西班牙语交谈。该学生被追踪到了。原来他正在完成英语和西班牙语的双学位。他说他早些时候上过霍夫的地球科学课程，两人成了朋友。
What had sounded like a heated argument to outsiders who didn't understand Spanish was actually them loudly teasing each other. Other leads involving various students were pursued, then dismissed as they went nowhere. In mid-February, three weeks after the murders, the Boston Globe ran a front-page story with the headline, Love Affair eyed in New Hampshire killings, husband involved with unidentified woman, officials say. The article went on to quote unnamed sources who claimed detectives believed the murders were a crime of passion that resulted from an affair Hoff was having.
在外人听来像是激烈的争吵，因为他们不懂西班牙语，实际上他们是在大声地互相开玩笑。其他涉及多名学生的线索被追踪，然后因毫无进展而被驳回。2月中旬，谋杀案发生三周后，《波士顿环球报》在头版刊登了一篇报道，标题为“新罕布什尔州杀人案指向婚外情，官员称丈夫与身份不明的女性有染”。文章引用了匿名消息来源，声称侦探们认为谋杀案是一起因霍夫婚外情引发的激情犯罪。
Investigators suspected a lone man was behind the attack as the weapon used was heavy. The person most likely responsible was the husband or partner of the woman Hoff was involved with. This article outraged friends of the Xantops who wrote angry letters to the newspaper in response. They were adamant that Hoff and Susanna were deeply in love and committed to one another, and there was no indication of any infidelity. Two days later, New Hampshire's Attorney General publicly disputed the contents of the article, saying that investigators did not think an affair was the motive for the murders. The Boston Globe subsequently ran a retraction.
调查人员怀疑一名独行男子是袭击的幕后黑手，因为使用的武器很重。最有可能负责的人是霍夫与之有染的女性的丈夫或伴侣。这篇文章激怒了赞托普夫妇的朋友，他们写了愤怒的信给报社作为回应。他们坚称霍夫和苏珊娜深爱对方，对彼此忠诚，没有任何不忠的迹象。两天后，新罕布什尔州总检察长公开反驳了文章的内容，称调查人员并不认为婚外情是谋杀的动机。《波士顿环球报》随后发表了更正声明。
At the time, they had believed the information they had was accurate, but they now apologized to the Xantops family and friends for inadvertently causing more pain. From the outside, it looked like detectives weren't making any progress on the case. However, they had kept the biggest clue they had tightly under wraps from the media and the public. Two crucial items had been recovered from the crime scene. The matching knife sheaths. These had not belonged to the Xantops and were clearly left behind by the killer or killers. The fact that there were two indicated they were looking for more than one perpetrator.
当时，他们认为自己掌握的信息是准确的，但现在他们向赞托普的家人和朋友道歉，因为无意中造成了更多的痛苦。从外面看，侦探们似乎在案件上没有任何进展。然而，他们将掌握的最大线索对媒体和公众严加保密。从犯罪现场找回了两件关键物品：配套的刀鞘。这些不属于赞托普夫妇，显然是凶手或凶手们留下的。有两个刀鞘的事实表明，他们正在寻找不止一名肇事者。
An examination of the footlong hard plastic shafts. revealed that they were highly unique. They were designed to fit a very particular knife called an SOG Seal 2000. These knives were commando weapons with a 7-inch blade and a 5-inch black contoured handle. They had only been on the market for five years and were made in the state of Washington by a company called SOG Specialty Knives. The SOG Seal 2000 was named for the US Navy Seals and the one sold with the sheaths found that the Zantop residents had only been around for the past 10 months. This meant detectives were looking for two knives purchased within less than the last year. Unfortunately, the knives were widely available in a variety of stores and online retailers.
对一英尺长的硬塑料刀鞘的检查显示，它们非常独特。它们被设计用来装一种非常特殊的刀，叫做SOG Seal 2000。这些刀是突击队武器，有7英寸的刀片和5英寸的黑色轮廓手柄。它们上市仅五年，由华盛顿州一家名为SOG Specialty Knives的公司制造。SOG Seal 2000以美国海军海豹突击队命名，而在赞托普家发现的带有刀鞘的刀仅存在了过去10个月。这意味着侦探们正在寻找在过去不到一年内购买的两把刀。不幸的是，这些刀在各种商店和在线零售商处广泛销售。
Investigators obtained a list of shops and mail order catalogs that sold the knives in New Hampshire, as well as the neighbouring states of Connecticut, Vermont, Maine and New York. They began calling merchants one by one to ask for their records of SOG seal 2000 sales since March 2000. Detectives also contacted a large number of online retailers requesting their sales records. Roughly two weeks after the murders, SOG provided them with a 69-page list of buyers, merchants and distributors where they had shipped knives to during the relevant period. The list accounted for almost 5,000 knives. Detectives began the painstaking process of going through the list. On Wednesday, February 14, a detective noticed that a Massachusetts-based company called Fox Firearms had purchased 124 SOG seal 2,000
调查人员获得了一份在新罕布什尔州以及邻近的康涅狄格州、佛蒙特州、缅因州和纽约州销售这些刀具的商店和邮购目录清单。他们开始逐一打电话给商家，询问他们自2000年3月以来的SOG Seal 2000销售记录。侦探们还联系了大量在线零售商，要求提供他们的销售记录。谋杀案发生约两周后，SOG向他们提供了一份69页的买家、商家和分销商名单，他们在相关期间向这些地方运送了刀具。该名单涵盖了近5000把刀。侦探们开始进行梳理名单的艰苦过程。2月14日星期三，一名侦探注意到一家名为Fox Firearms的马萨诸塞州公司购买了124把SOG Seal 2000
knives, which was a far higher number than any other name on the list. The detective contacted the owner of Fox Firearms and learned he operated an online store out of his home. He'd received his order of 124 knives the previous June and had so far sold 84 of them. He faxed the detective a list of all he sales. As the detective scanned the list, one particular purchase stood out to him. Less than four weeks before the Zantot murders, a buyer who lived just 35 miles from Etna had purchased not one, but two knives. The buyer's name was James Parker, and he went by the online handle of Jimmy Bruce. He resided in Chelsea, a small town in Vermont, almost 35 miles directly north of Etna.
刀，这个数字远高于名单上的任何其他名字。侦探联系了Fox Firearms的老板，得知他在家里经营一家在线商店。他去年6月收到了124把刀的订单，到目前为止已经卖出了84把。他把所有销售清单传真给了侦探。当侦探扫描清单时，一个特定的购买引起了他的注意。在赞托普谋杀案发生不到四周前，一位住在离埃特纳仅35英里的买家购买了不止一把，而是两把刀。买家的名字是詹姆斯·帕克（James Parker），他使用的网名是Jimmy Bruce。他住在佛蒙特州的一个小镇切尔西（Chelsea），位于埃特纳正北约35英里处。
Three investigators drove immediately to Chelsea to make some inquiries. They were stunned to learn that James Parker was a high school student, and he was just 16 years old. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Just before 7pm on Thursday, February 15, the investigators pulled up at the address James Parker had supplied when buying the knives.
三名调查人员立即开车前往切尔西进行询问。他们震惊地得知詹姆斯·帕克是一名高中生，年仅16岁。案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。2月15日星期四晚上7点前，调查人员抵达了詹姆斯·帕克购买刀具时提供的地址。
It was a red, a frame house situated on a 38-acre lock. The detectives knocked on the front door and it was answered by the home's owner, John Parker. The detectives introduced themselves and explained that they were there to discuss some knives which his son had bought. John Parker invited them in and took them through to the kitchen. Sitting on a stool there was a clean-cut teenage boy with spiky dark hair. It was James, whose friends called him Jim. One of the detectives explained that they were under no obligation to speak with them, but both John and James Parker agreed that it would be fine.
那是一栋红色的A型框架房屋，坐落在一块38英亩的土地上。侦探们敲了前门，房主约翰·帕克（John Parker）开了门。侦探们介绍了自己，并解释说他们来这里是为了讨论他儿子买的一些刀。约翰·帕克邀请他们进去，并带他们去了厨房。坐在凳子上的是一个干净利落、留着尖刺深色头发的少年。他就是詹姆斯，朋友们叫他吉姆。其中一名侦探解释说，他们没有义务与他们交谈，但约翰和詹姆斯·帕克都同意没问题。
Sitting at the kitchen table with his father and the three officers, James explained that he and his friend Robert Tulloch had purchased the knives to use while camping. The two boys loved the outdoors and had dreams of traveling to Colorado and even overseas to go rock climbing. They thought the knives would be useful for cutting down branches to build forts. However, when they tried using the footlong weapons, they found that they were too big, so they decided to resell them. Not long after receiving the knives the previous month, James and Robert had driven to an army goods store in the larger city of Burlington
詹姆斯和父亲以及三名警官坐在餐桌旁，解释说他和朋友罗伯特·塔洛赫（Robert Tulloch）购买这些刀是为了露营时使用。这两个男孩热爱户外活动，梦想着去科罗拉多甚至海外攀岩。他们认为这些刀对于砍伐树枝建造堡垒很有用。然而，当他们尝试使用这些一英尺长的武器时，发现它们太大了，所以决定转卖。上个月收到刀后不久，詹姆斯和罗伯特开车去了伯灵顿（Burlington）大城市的一家军用品店，
to see if the shop owner was interested in them. He wasn't, but a customer overheard their conversation and offered the boys $60 per knife. The teenagers weren't thrilled with the offer, as they'd hoped for more than double that, but they ultimately agreed. When asked what the customer looked like, James described him as scruffy-looking with dark hair, either black or brown. The man was between 5'9 and 6 feet tall. At first, James said he was in his early 20s, but then added he might have been in his 30s.
看看店主是否对它们感兴趣。店主不感兴趣，但一名顾客听到了他们的谈话，并提出以每把60美元的价格购买。青少年们对这个报价并不兴奋，因为他们希望价格能翻倍，但最终还是同意了。当被问及那名顾客长什么样时，詹姆斯形容他看起来邋遢，留着深色头发，黑色或棕色。那名男子身高在5英尺9英寸到6英尺之间。起初，詹姆斯说他20出头，但后来补充说他可能30多岁。
When asked if he'd heard about the murder of two Dartmouth's, professors in the neighboring state of New Hampshire, James said he hadn't. The detectives asked if James would be willing to provide them with his fingerprints. He said he would. He and his father accompanied the detectives to the local sheriff's office to do so right away. James Parker seemed like a nice young man with a supportive family who'd grown up in a lovely middle-class home. He was in his second last year of high school with no criminal history, and the detectives found it highly unlikely that he could be behind the brutal murder of Hoff and Susanna Zantop. Officers paid a visit to James Parker's friend Robert Tulloch to get his version of the Knife
当被问及是否听说过邻州新罕布什尔州两名达特茅斯教授被谋杀的消息时，詹姆斯说他没有。侦探们问詹姆斯是否愿意提供指纹。他说他愿意。他和父亲陪同侦探们立即前往当地治安官办公室进行指纹采集。詹姆斯·帕克看起来像是一个有着支持他的家庭、在一个可爱的中产阶级家庭中长大的好少年。他正在读高二，没有犯罪记录，侦探们认为他不太可能是霍夫和苏珊娜·赞托普残酷谋杀案的幕后黑手。警官们拜访了詹姆斯·帕克的朋友罗伯特·塔洛赫，以获取他关于刀具的说法。
story. They chatted with Robert's parents before meeting the 17-year-old, who was six feet tall and lanky. He seemed calm and mature for his age. While James had appeared slightly nervous to be speaking with police, Robert was relaxed and articulate. He repeated what James had told them about the knives, but couldn't describe the man who'd bought them as James had looked after that. Robert explained that they hadn't told their parents about buying the two weapons because they knew they wouldn't approve. Robert told the detectives how he and James liked to rock climb. They asked if the pair had done any climbing lately.
故事。他们在见到17岁、身高六英尺、身材瘦长的罗伯特之前，先与罗伯特的父母聊了聊。他看起来比同龄人冷静成熟。虽然詹姆斯在与警察交谈时显得有些紧张，但罗伯特却很放松且口齿伶俐。他重复了詹姆斯告诉他们的关于刀具的事情，但无法描述买刀的那个男人，因为那是詹姆斯负责的。罗伯特解释说，他们没有告诉父母购买这两件武器，因为他们知道父母不会赞成。罗伯特告诉侦探他和詹姆斯喜欢攀岩。他们问这对搭档最近是否去攀岩了。
Robert said he'd recently clambered over a snowbank and had an accident, cutting his leg on a metal spigot that was jutting out of a maple tree. These spigots were used to tap maple trees for syrup, which is a big industry in Vermont. Like his friend, Robert readily agreed to provide his fingerprints. Detectives also asked if they could take a look at Robert's shoes. He showed them two pairs. he wore often, some Nike sneakers and a pair of Vask hiking boots.
罗伯特说他最近爬过一个雪堆时发生了意外，腿被一棵枫树上突出的金属龙头割伤了。这些龙头被用来采集枫糖浆，这是佛蒙特州的一大产业。像他的朋友一样，罗伯特欣然同意提供指纹。侦探们还询问是否可以看看罗伯特的鞋子。他给他们看了两双他常穿的鞋，一些耐克运动鞋和一双Vask登山靴。
The boots were the same size as those that had left Prince at the Zantop House, prompting detectives to ask if they could take them. Again, Robert agreed. He too went to the sheriff's office to provide his fingerprints, then both boys were permitted to return home with their parents. At around 11 a.m. the following day of Friday, February 16, the case's lead investigator received a phone call from John Parker, James's father. John didn't beat around the bush, telling the detective,
这些靴子的大小与在赞托普家留下的印记相同，促使侦探们询问是否可以带走它们。罗伯特再次同意了。他也去了治安官办公室提供指纹，然后两个男孩都被允许和父母回家。第二天，即2月16日星期五上午11点左右，案件的首席调查员接到了詹姆斯父亲约翰·帕克的电话。约翰没有绕弯子，告诉侦探：
Jimmy's gone. John and his wife Joan had been woken at around 3 a.m. by the sound of James's 1987 Silver Audi starting up. John and Joan leapt out of bed and ran to the window and called out to their son to stop, but he ignored them and drove away. The couple later discovered a note that James had scribbled and left for them. It read, I just had to talk to Robert alone. I will be back in the morning. Don't call cops.
“吉米不见了。”约翰和他的妻子琼（Joan）在凌晨3点左右被詹姆斯1987年的银色奥迪启动的声音惊醒。约翰和琼跳下床跑到窗边，大声叫儿子停下，但他无视他们开车离开了。这对夫妇后来发现了一张詹姆斯潦草写下留给他们的字条。上面写着：“我只是必须单独和罗伯特谈谈。我早上会回来。别报警。”
This reassured John and Joan somewhat. Their son had been through a shocking experience the day prior, and it made sense he would want to discuss it with his friend who was going through the same thing. However, they had told James he shouldn't speak to Robert for the time being, and Robert's parents had done the same. John decided to head out and go looking for the boys. He drove around town for an hour but found no trace of them. He and Jones spoke with Mike and Diantulik, Robert's parents,
这让约翰和琼稍微放心了一些。他们的儿子前一天经历了一次令人震惊的经历，他想和同样经历这件事的朋友讨论一下也是合情合理的。然而，他们曾告诉詹姆斯暂时不要和罗伯特说话，罗伯特的父母也做了同样的事情。约翰决定出去寻找男孩们。他在城里转了一个小时，但没有发现他们的踪迹。他和琼与罗伯特的父母迈克（Mike）和迪安·塔利克（Dian Tulik）谈过，
and while they all initially shared the same hope that their sons were just talking together somewhere, as the hours continued to pass, they began to worry. John eventually made the decision to ignore James' request and phone the police. The news that the teenagers had taken off came as a shock to detectives. They had seen no signs that the two had any intention of running away, and were still unsure if they were even involved in the Zantop murders. The card on Robert's leg had seemed suspicious, as did his vask boots, but the boys hadn't seemed like killers.
虽然他们最初都怀着同样的希望，即他们的儿子只是在某个地方谈话，但随着时间的流逝，他们开始担心起来。约翰最终决定无视詹姆斯的请求，打电话给警察。青少年们出走的消息让侦探们感到震惊。他们没有看到任何迹象表明两人有逃跑的打算，而且仍然不确定他们是否参与了赞托普谋杀案。罗伯特腿上的伤口看起来很可疑，他的Vask靴子也是，但男孩们看起来不像杀人犯。
At most, they had suspected maybe one of the teenagers was covering for someone. A search was immediately launched for the teens and worked. began to spread through the small close-knit community of Chelsea that two local boys were wanted by police. Their high school was contacted, but no one there had seen Robert or James. They hadn't shown up for classes that day. Police warned the principal that if they did show up, they should not be allowed into the school. They should lock the doors and call the police immediately. Less than two years earlier, the United States had been shocked and forever altered by the Columbine Massacre, a tragedy in which two friends had committed a mass shooting at their high school.
充其量，他们怀疑可能其中一个青少年在为某人掩盖。搜寻工作立即展开，关于两名当地男孩被警方通缉的消息开始在切尔西这个紧密团结的小社区中传播。他们的学校被联系，但那里没有人见过罗伯特或詹姆斯。他们那天没有去上课。警察警告校长，如果他们出现，不应该让他们进入学校。他们应该锁上门并立即报警。不到两年前，美国被科伦拜恩大屠杀震惊并永远改变了，那是一场两名朋友在高中进行大规模枪击的悲剧。
Now facing their own violent crime perpetrated by a pair of teenage boys, New Hampshire investigators were scared of what might happen next. But friends and teachers of the boys couldn't understand why they would be sought by law enforcement. The worst they could imagine was that Robert and James had maybe done something online, like posted a joke that was misinterpreted. James Parker had an active, happy childhood with his parents and older sister. He loved to build forts, go fishing, play basketball, and ride his dirt bike. He lost interest in playing organized sports as he got older, instead becoming interested in music.
现在面对由两个十几岁男孩犯下的暴力犯罪，新罕布什尔州的调查人员害怕接下来会发生什么。但男孩们的朋友和老师无法理解他们为什么会被执法部门搜捕。他们能想象到的最坏情况是，罗伯特和詹姆斯可能在网上做了什么，比如发布了一个被误解的笑话。詹姆斯·帕克与父母和姐姐度过了一个活跃、快乐的童年。他喜欢建造堡垒、钓鱼、打篮球和骑越野摩托车。随着年龄的增长，他对参加有组织的体育运动失去了兴趣，转而对音乐产生了兴趣。
He also wanted to stand out and could be a bit of a show-off for it. class clown. James was intelligent, but he found school boring and began dreaming of living a bigger life in someplace more exciting than Chelsea. He became friends with Robert Tulloch in middle school, after Robert's family relocated to Vermont from Florida. Even though Robert was one year older than James and in another class, they had the same loud, talkative energy and outdoorsy interests. The two became even closer as they got older, spending more time together without other friends. One of their favorite ways to pass the time was rock climbing. By mid-2000, it was obvious to everyone that the pair were best friends.
他也想脱颖而出，可能会因为是班级小丑而有点爱炫耀。詹姆斯很聪明，但他觉得学校很无聊，开始梦想在比切尔西更令人兴奋的地方过上更广阔的生活。他在初中时与罗伯特·塔洛赫成为朋友，当时罗伯特的家人从佛罗里达搬到了佛蒙特州。尽管罗伯特比詹姆斯大一岁，在另一个班级，但他们有着同样大声、健谈的精力和户外兴趣。随着年龄的增长，两人变得更加亲密，在没有其他朋友的情况下花更多时间在一起。他们最喜欢的消磨时间的方式之一是攀岩。到2000年中期，每个人都很明显这对搭档是最好的朋友。
Those who knew them said that Robert was the leader of the two, and the younger James seemed to be more of a follower. But it had never seemed untoward or toxic. Both boys were bright and doing quite well in school. James was a talented musician and a drama student, as well as a well-liked class clown. Robert was a gifted member of the school's debate team and had been elected student council president. In fact, he was so far ahead on his credits that he was on track to graduating high school without having to attend many of his senior year classes. Neither boy was interested in partying, drinking or drugs. The only criticism some people had of them was that they seemed to think they were smarter than everyone else.
认识他们的人说，罗伯特是两人中的领导者，而年轻的詹姆斯似乎更像是一个追随者。但这从来没有显得不正当或有毒。两个男孩都很聪明，在学校表现相当不错。詹姆斯是一位有天赋的音乐家和戏剧学生，也是一位受欢迎的班级小丑。罗伯特是学校辩论队的天才成员，并被选为学生会主席。事实上，他的学分领先太多，以至于他有望在不参加大部分高三课程的情况下从高中毕业。两个男孩对聚会、饮酒或毒品都不感兴趣。人们对他们唯一的批评是，他们似乎认为自己比其他任何人都聪明。
Something strange that had happened recently was that the two boys had abruptly taken off on an impromptu road trip on the morning of Wednesday, January 31, four days after the Xanops were murdered. That night, James had called his parents to tell them he and Robert had caught a bus interstate, He wouldn't say where they were headed. The next morning, he called again to say they were in St. Louis, Missouri, but they wanted to come home. Their parents booked them flights back to New Hampshire. When friends grilled them about the trip, all they would say was that they'd intended to go rock climbing in Colorado. Investigators kept a watch over the teenager's parents and homes.
最近发生的一件奇怪的事情是，两个男孩在1月31日星期三早上，即赞托普夫妇被谋杀四天后，突然进行了一次即兴公路旅行。那天晚上，詹姆斯打电话给父母，告诉他们他和罗伯特乘巴士去了州外。他没有说他们要去哪里。第二天早上，他再次打电话说他们在密苏里州的圣路易斯，但他们想回家。他们的父母预订了他们回新罕布什尔州的航班。当朋友们盘问他们关于这次旅行的事情时，他们只会说他们打算去科罗拉多州攀岩。调查人员监视着这些青少年的父母和家。
By late afternoon, they received a word that James Parker's fingerprints match. a print found on one of the knife sheaths found in the Zantop home. This confirmed that the knives the teenagers had bought were the same ones used to murder the professors. Detectives secured search warrants for the Parker and Tullick homes, and later that night, two separate teams of forensic investigators headed to each house. The primary focus was on the teenager's bedrooms. Robert Tullick's room was upstairs, alone in the front corner. corner of the house. Clothes was strewn across the floor along with a mattress. There was also a
到深夜，他们收到消息说詹姆斯·帕克的指纹与在赞托普家中发现的一个刀鞘上的指纹相符。这证实了青少年购买的刀具就是用来谋杀教授的同一批刀具。侦探们获得了对帕克和塔利克家进行搜查的搜查令，那天晚上晚些时候，两支独立的法医调查小组前往每栋房子。主要重点是青少年的卧室。罗伯特·塔利克的房间在楼上，独自在房子的前角。衣服散落在地板上，还有一张床垫。还有一个
closet, a chair and a bookshelf. Rock climbing equipment was attached to one wall. Investigators seized books, pieces of paper, computers and items of clothing. One investigator noticed a cardboard box on the floor in a corner next to a small bin. A few notebooks and writing pads lay on top of the box. The investigators moved the notebooks aside and opened up the box. Inside was a large stash of comic books. Lying on top of the comics were two items, almost entirely wrapped in fabric and duct tape. But a portion of the items were exposed, the black handles of two SOGC or 2000 knives. The knives were subsequently unwrapped.
壁橱、一把椅子和一个书架。一面墙上挂着攀岩装备。调查人员查获了书籍、纸张、电脑和衣物。一名调查人员注意到角落里一个小垃圾桶旁边放着一个纸板箱。箱子上放着几本笔记本和写字板。调查人员移开笔记本，打开了箱子。里面藏着一大堆漫画书。漫画书上面放着两件几乎完全被布和管道胶带包裹的东西。但这些物品的一部分露了出来，那是两把SOG Seal 2000刀具的黑色刀柄。随后，这些刀具被拆开了包装。
One had been taped up inside a sock and the other was inside a mitten. There appeared to be blood stains on the blades. Testing would later confirm that the blood belonged to Susanna Zantop. By now, the story of the two fugitive teens was big news across New England. A massive search was underway across the region. An off-duty officer near Sturbridge in Massachusetts recall giving directions to two years. young men who matched the teen's description at a gas station before news of their fugitive status had broken. This prompted investigators to focus on the Sturbridge area.
其中一把被胶带缠在一只袜子里，另一把则装在一只连指手套里。刀刃上似乎有血迹。后来的检测证实，这些血迹属于苏珊娜·赞托普（Susanna Zantop）。此时，两名逃亡少年的故事已成为整个新英格兰地区的大新闻。该地区正在进行大规模搜捕。马萨诸塞州斯特布里奇（Sturbridge）附近的一名休班警官回忆说，在两名少年的逃亡身份曝光前，他在一家加油站给两名符合描述的年轻人指过路。这促使调查人员将重点放在了斯特布里奇地区。
Late on Saturday, February 17, a Massachusetts state trooper was keeping a lookout for any sign of the runaway teens during his shift. At a truck stop in Sturbridge, he noticed a silver Audi parked in the lot that was covered in snow, indicating it had been there a while. It also had a Vermont license plate. Worried that the teenagers might be hiding inside, the trooper cautiously approached the vehicle. The license plate details matched Jim Parker's Audi. But aside from some belongings and crackers spread across the seats, it was empty. It appeared that the boys had abandoned it shortly after running away and found another way
2月17日星期六深夜，一名马萨诸塞州州警在值班时留意着这两名逃亡少年的踪迹。在斯特布里奇的一个卡车停靠站，他注意到停车场里停着一辆银色的奥迪，车身上覆盖着积雪，说明它已经停在那里有一段时间了。车上还挂着佛蒙特州的车牌。担心少年们可能躲在车里，警官小心翼翼地靠近了车辆。车牌信息与吉姆·帕克（Jim Parker）的奥迪相符。但除了座位上散落的一些物品和饼干外，车里空无一人。看来这两个男孩在逃跑后不久就弃车，并找到了其他方式
to keep fleeing. Rowdy Kyle Tucker was a 30-something truck driver from from Alabama, who'd stopped for a bite to eat at the Sturbridge truck stop on the evening of Friday, February 16. He was accompanied by his wife, Nancy, who was helping Routy out with the drive. The couple noticed two teenage boys carrying backpacks and begging for a ride from other truckers. Nancy was keen to help them out. Routy agreed, and they offered the young men a lift in their in 1999 white Peterbilt truck, which had green flames painted on the bonnet. The teenagers introduced themselves as Sam and Tyler and said they were planning to hitchhike
继续逃亡。罗迪·凯尔·塔克（Rowdy Kyle Tucker）是一位来自阿拉巴马州的30多岁卡车司机，2月16日星期五晚上，他在斯特布里奇的卡车停靠站停下来吃点东西。他的妻子南希（Nancy）陪同他，并协助他开车。这对夫妇注意到两名十几岁的男孩背着背包，正向其他卡车司机乞求搭便车。南希很想帮助他们。罗迪同意了，他们便让这两个年轻人搭乘他们1999年的白色彼得比尔特（Peterbilt）卡车，卡车引擎盖上绘有绿色火焰。少年们自称是萨姆（Sam）和泰勒（Tyler），并说他们计划搭便车
all the way to Southern California in search of work. The tuckers empathised with the two young men and Nancy even offered to give them the number of her sister in California in case they needed help when they got there. The couple took them as far as Columbia, New Jersey, which was a distance of 220, miles from where they'd picked them up. They reached the Columbia truck stop in the middle of the afternoon on Saturday, February 17. Before dropping them off and continuing on their way, the tuckers let Sam and Tyler use their CB radio to ask if any other truckers in the area could give them a lift. One trucker named James Hicks responded saying he didn't think he could offer a ride, but the
一路前往南加州寻找工作。塔克夫妇对这两个年轻人表示同情，南希甚至主动提出给他们她在加州的妹妹的电话号码，以防他们到达那里后需要帮助。这对夫妇载着他们一直到了新泽西州的哥伦比亚（Columbia），距离他们接上他们的地方有220英里。他们在2月17日星期六下午到达了哥伦比亚卡车停靠站。在放下他们继续赶路之前，塔克夫妇让萨姆和泰勒使用他们的CB无线电，询问该地区是否有其他卡车司机可以载他们一程。一位名叫詹姆斯·希克斯（James Hicks）的卡车司机回应说，他认为自己无法提供搭乘，但
teenagers were welcome to hang out in his truck's cab if they needed somewhere warm to rest until they found one. They accepted his offer. James was watching his satellite television when they got in and a news report came on about two Vermont teenagers on the run who were wanted for questioning in relation to a double murder. The teenagers asked James to switch over to the Weather Channel, and he obliged. The teens were clearly exhausted and soon fell asleep. James felt sorry for them. He had three teenage sons of his own, one of whom had died just four months earlier in a motorbike accident. It went against company policy to pick up hitchhikers, and James had never done so before, but he decided he'd give these boys a lift after all.
如果他们需要一个温暖的地方休息直到找到车，欢迎他们待在他的卡车驾驶室里。他们接受了他的提议。詹姆斯上车时正在看卫星电视，新闻报道中提到了两名佛蒙特州少年在逃，他们因涉嫌一起双重谋杀案而被通缉。少年们要求詹姆斯换到天气频道，他照做了。少年们显然精疲力竭，很快就睡着了。詹姆斯为他们感到难过。他自己有三个十几岁的儿子，其中一个在四个月前死于摩托车事故。虽然公司规定不允许搭载搭便车的人，詹姆斯以前也从未这样做过，但他最终还是决定载这两个男孩一程。
He was headed west, which was the general direction the young men wanted to go. They left New Jersey on Sunday morning, as they headed towards a truck stop in Spicerland, Indiana, James used his CB radio to put a call out for anyone who could take the teens from here. His final destination was north in Chicago, but the teenagers wanted to keep going west. Can anybody give a ride to two boys who want to go to California? James asked. He added that he'd picked up the young hitchhikers in New Jersey. After a brief moment, a reply crackled through. Sure, I can, said a man's voice.
他正向西行驶，这正是年轻人想去的方向。他们于周日早上离开新泽西州，在前往印第安纳州斯派斯兰（Spiceland）的卡车停靠站时，詹姆斯使用他的CB无线电呼叫，看是否有人能从这里接走这些少年。他的最终目的地是北部的芝加哥，但少年们想继续向西走。詹姆斯问道：“有人能载两个想去加州的男孩吗？”他补充说，他是在新泽西州接到的这两个年轻的搭车客。片刻之后，无线电里传来了回复。一个男人的声音说：“当然，我可以。”
It was 3.45 a.m. on Monday, February 19, when James Hicks's truck pulled into the Spiceland truck stop. He'd agreed with the other trucker to drop the teenagers off at the fuel desk. As James said goodbye to Sam and Tyler, he handed over a $10 note and told them to use it to buy some breakfast. The teens clambered out of James' truck and stood by the fuel pumps, waiting for their ride. To their surprise, two deputies from a car. a local sheriff's department approached instead. They separated the young men and began speaking to them separately, asking them for their names, birthdays and identification. Neither had ID on them. One said his name was Tyler J. Jones. When asked what the J. stood for, he paused noticeably
2月19日星期一凌晨3点45分，詹姆斯·希克斯的卡车驶入了斯派斯兰卡车停靠站。他已与另一位卡车司机约定在加油台放下这些少年。当詹姆斯与萨姆和泰勒告别时，他递给他们一张10美元的钞票，让他们买点早餐。少年们爬下詹姆斯的卡车，站在加油泵旁等待他们的车。令他们惊讶的是，两名来自当地治安官部门的副警长走了过来。他们将两个年轻人分开，开始分别与他们交谈，询问他们的姓名、生日和身份证件。两人身上都没有证件。其中一人说他叫泰勒·J·琼斯（Tyler J. Jones）。当被问及J代表什么时，他明显停顿了一下
before stating, Jeffrey. The other boy said his date of birth was March 40, 19, before clarifying that he meant March 30. Then a message came over the deputies dispatch radio, which included the name Robert Tulloch. Upon hearing this, the boy who'd claimed to be Sam said, It's me you are looking for. You've got us. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's
然后说，杰弗里（Jeffrey）。另一个男孩说他的出生日期是3月40日，19...，随后澄清说他指的是3月30日。接着，副警长的调度无线电中传来一条消息，其中包含了罗伯特·塔洛赫（Robert Tulloch）的名字。听到这个名字，那个自称萨姆的男孩说：“你们要找的就是我。你们抓到我们了。”案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商的内容来支持我们。感谢您收听本集
ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. After James Parker's Silver Audi was found at a Sturbridge truck stop in Massachusetts, investigators had reviewed CCTV footage from the location. It showed James Parker and Robert Tulloch climbing into a white 1999 Peterbill truck with green flames on the bonnet. They traced the truck to its company, which led them to Rowdy Kyle and Nancy Tucker. Because detectives weren't sure if the teenagers were still travelling with the couple or not, they didn't try calling Rowdy's cell phone for fear of spooking them. Instead, they tracked the truck via a global positioning system.
广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Case File继续提供高质量的内容。在詹姆斯·帕克的银色奥迪在马萨诸塞州斯特布里奇的卡车停靠站被发现后，调查人员查看了该地点的闭路电视录像。录像显示詹姆斯·帕克和罗伯特·塔洛赫爬上了一辆引擎盖上有绿色火焰的白色1999年彼得比尔特卡车。他们追踪到该卡车所属的公司，从而找到了罗迪·凯尔和南希·塔克。由于侦探们不确定少年们是否还和这对夫妇在一起，他们不敢拨打罗迪的手机，以免惊动他们。相反，他们通过全球定位系统追踪了这辆卡车。
When the couple stopped in Pennsylvania for arrest, investigators swooped. They learned that the tuckers had already dropped off the boys at a stop in New Jersey, where they'd met up with a trucker heading west. Meanwhile, Sergeant Bill Ward of the Henry County Sheriff's Department in Indiana was following the case. He'd heard a news report about the fugitive teens and how they were supposedly fleeing west. Sergeant Ward thought that might make it likely that they'd passed through his jurisdiction on their way as the busy East-West Highway Interstate 70 cut right through the county. During a shift, Sergeant Ward decided to patrol the nearby flying
当这对夫妇在宾夕法尼亚州停车休息时，调查人员迅速出动。他们得知塔克夫妇已经把男孩们放在了新泽西州的一个停靠站，在那里他们遇到了一个向西行驶的卡车司机。与此同时，印第安纳州亨利县治安官部门的比尔·沃德（Bill Ward）警长正在关注此案。他听到了关于逃亡少年以及他们据称正向西逃窜的新闻报道。沃德警长认为，他们很有可能在前往西部的途中经过他的辖区，因为繁忙的70号州际公路东西向高速公路正好穿过该县。在值班期间，沃德警长决定巡逻附近的飞J（Flying J）
J truck stop and keep an ear out on his radio for any CB chatter. He heard James Hicks' request for someone to offer two teenage boys a lift. Without hesitating, Sergeant Ward replied, sure, I can. Then he put in a call for backup and waited for the truck to arrive. The sergeant's hunch proved correct, and the two teens turned out to be the fugitives he was looking for. After seeing the deputies' handcuff James and Robert then placed them in their cruisers, trucker James Hicks approached.
卡车停靠站，并留意无线电中的CB聊天。他听到了詹姆斯·希克斯请求有人载两个十几岁男孩的请求。沃德警长毫不犹豫地回答：“当然，我可以。”然后他呼叫了增援，并等待卡车到达。警长的直觉被证明是正确的，这两个少年正是他要寻找的逃犯。在看到副警长给詹姆斯和罗伯特戴上手铐并将他们放入巡逻车后，卡车司机詹姆斯·希克斯走了过来。
He asked why they were being arrested and was told that they were wanted for murder. Angered by this revelation, James told the deputies that he'd given the teens $10 for breakfast, but now he wanted it back. The deputies retrieved it for him. A press conference was soon held to notify the public that the suspects and the suspects and Zantop murders had been apprehended. But when asked by journalists what the motive for the crime was, detectives still didn't have an answer. ABC News had reported that detectives found books related to white supremacy and Naziism in Robert Tulloch's bedroom. The Zantops had always been
他询问他们为什么被捕，并被告知他们因谋杀罪被通缉。詹姆斯对这一消息感到愤怒，他告诉副警长，他给了少年们10美元买早餐，但现在他想要回来。副警长为他取回了钱。不久后举行了新闻发布会，通知公众赞托普谋杀案的嫌疑人已被逮捕。但当记者询问犯罪动机时，侦探们仍然没有答案。美国广播公司新闻报道称，侦探在罗伯特·塔洛赫的卧室里发现了与白人至上主义和纳粹主义有关的书籍。赞托普夫妇一直
outspoken in their belief that their native Germany should make amends for the Holocaust and its Nazi past. Reporters speculated whether the teenagers had been outspoken. had chosen the couple because of their political beliefs, but detectives had found no evidence of that. James Parker and Robert Tulloch were taken to the Henry County Jail in Indiana. Rather than hold the teenagers with the other inmates, James was taken to an interview room and Robert was held in a wait room. Both cried heavily for hours. Under guidance from his parents and their lawyer, Jim didn't speak to investigators. Robert was taken to speak with an FBI agent and sobbed throughout the interrogation, saying,
直言不讳地认为他们的祖国德国应该为大屠杀及其纳粹过去进行赔偿。记者们猜测这些少年是否因为这对夫妇的政治信仰而选择了他们，但侦探们没有发现任何证据。詹姆斯·帕克和罗伯特·塔洛赫被带到印第安纳州的亨利县监狱。詹姆斯没有和其他囚犯关在一起，而是被带到了审讯室，罗伯特则被关在候审室。两人都痛哭了几个小时。在父母和律师的指导下，吉姆没有与调查人员交谈。罗伯特被带去与一名联邦调查局特工交谈，他在审讯过程中一直啜泣，说道：
It was pretty easy to throw my life away. At one point, he repeated the words, I'm so sorry, Jim, I'm so sorry Jim, over and over. But he said nothing about the crimes he was in custody for. Both teenagers agreed to waive extradition and voluntarily returned to New Hampshire. Back in Chelsea, their parents were interviewed by investigators. All four of them told detectives that they had no idea who Hoff and Susanna Zantop were and knew of no reason why their sons would murder them. As far as they were aware, there was no connection between Jim and Robert and the couple.
“毁掉我的人生太容易了。”在某一时刻，他一遍又一遍地重复着：“我很抱歉，吉姆，我很抱歉，吉姆。”但他对所涉罪行只字未提。两名少年都同意放弃引渡，并自愿返回新罕布什尔州。回到切尔西（Chelsea），他们的父母接受了调查人员的采访。他们四人都告诉侦探，他们根本不知道霍夫（Hoff）和苏珊娜·赞托普是谁，也不知道他们的儿子为什么要谋杀他们。据他们所知，吉姆和罗伯特与这对夫妇之间没有任何联系。
The teenagers' families found it impossible to believe they were involved, even when they learnt that the knives used to kill the couple were found. in Robert's room. A boot print recovered at the scene also matched Robert's left boot. Despite popular opinion that the teenagers had always been well-behaved, investigators discovered this wasn't their first brush with the law. Almost a year earlier in April of 2000, a Chelsea resident named Robin Mix had returned home to find Jim, Robert and two other boys in his basement,
少年们的家人无法相信他们参与其中，即使在得知杀害这对夫妇的刀具是在罗伯特的房间里发现时也是如此。在现场发现的一个靴子印也与罗伯特的左靴相符。尽管普遍认为这些少年一直表现良好，但调查人员发现这并不是他们第一次触犯法律。大约一年前的2000年4月，一位名叫罗宾·米克斯（Robin Mix）的切尔西居民回到家，发现吉姆、罗伯特和其他两个男孩在他的地下室里，
cooking spaghetti and watching a movie. It turned out the boys were friends with Robin's twin daughters who had invited them over. When the teens arrived at the house, no one was home, but one of the doors was unlocked, so they let themselves in and stayed all afternoon. Robin wasn't happy about the intrusion, but he didn't report the incident. However, a few months later, there was another similar situation. Jim, Robert and some of their friends let themselves into the home of another classmate. whose family was on vacation.
煮着意大利面，看着电影。原来这些男孩是罗宾双胞胎女儿的朋友，女儿们邀请他们过来。当少年们到达房子时，家里没有人，但其中一扇门没锁，所以他们就自己进去了，并在那里待了整个下午。罗宾对这种入侵并不高兴，但他没有报告这起事件。然而，几个月后，又发生了类似的情况。吉姆、罗伯特和他们的一些朋友闯入了另一位同学的家，
They later said they did so was a prank. Nothing was taken from the house, and when the family found out about it, like Robin Mix, they were reluctant to report it. But when the property's owner, who rented the house to the family, heard about the matter, she phoned the police. The teenagers were subsequently referred to a court diversion program for juveniles, which they completed. They were also questioned in relation to a series of other break-ins in the area, but weren't charged for any.
该同学的家人当时正在度假。他们后来声称这样做只是个恶作剧。房子里什么也没丢，当这家人发现这件事时，像罗宾·米克斯一样，他们不愿报告。但当将房子租给这户人家的房主听说此事后，她报了警。这些少年随后被转介到青少年法院分流计划，并完成了该计划。他们还因该地区发生的一系列其他入室盗窃案而受到讯问，但并未受到指控。
Even though these incidents pointed to a pattern of misbehaviour, they were nothing like the grisly scene discovered at the Zantop residence. A few months later in June of 2001, a sheriff's deputy was transferring an inmate from Grafton County Jail to a different county, where he was being charged with passing bad checks and forgery. The two chatted as they drove, with the inmate whose nickname was Ranger telling the deputy about how he'd ended up in jail. Ranger added that he'd been housed in a cell close to Robert Tulloch, who was being held on remand until it was time for him to face trial for the Dartmouth murders. The deputy told Ranger that the double homicide was a shame and said that while the evidence against the two suspects was strong, investigators still hadn't figured out what their motive could have been. Ranger told the deputy that not only had Robert admitted to committing the crime,
尽管这些事件表明存在行为不端的模式，但它们与在赞托普住所发现的恐怖现场完全不同。几个月后的2001年6月，一名治安官副警长正在将一名囚犯从格拉夫顿县（Grafton County）监狱转移到另一个县，该囚犯因开空头支票和伪造罪被起诉。两人在开车时聊天，绰号为“游骑兵”（Ranger）的囚犯告诉副警长他是如何入狱的。游骑兵补充说，他曾被关在罗伯特·塔洛赫隔壁的牢房里，罗伯特因达特茅斯（Dartmouth）谋杀案被还押候审。副警长告诉游骑兵，这起双重谋杀案很可惜，并说虽然针对两名嫌疑人的证据很充分，但调查人员仍然没有弄清楚他们的动机可能是什么。游骑兵告诉副警长，罗伯特不仅承认犯下了罪行，
he had told him what the motive was. Apparently, it was because Robert had never killed anyone before and, quote, he was nervous and wanted to get a few under his belt. As for why the Xantops were chosen, that had been totally random. Robert and Jim had initially intended to attack the couple's next door nature, but they hadn't been home. Ranger also mentioned that the only thing the teenagers had taken from the scene was Hoff Zantop's wallet. The deputy passed the information on to a member of the team handling the Zantop case,
他还告诉了他动机是什么。显然，这是因为罗伯特以前从未杀过人，而且，引用他的话，“他很紧张，想练练手。”至于为什么选择赞托普夫妇，那完全是随机的。罗伯特和吉姆最初打算袭击这对夫妇的邻居，但他们当时不在家。游骑兵还提到，少年们从现场拿走的唯一东西是霍夫·赞托普的钱包。副警长将这些信息传递给了负责赞托普案的团队成员，
who was immediately struck by Ranger's revelations. It was true that the only item missing from the Zantop residence was Hoff's wallet, and that information had been withheld from the public. A meeting with Ranger was arranged where he shared more insight into the crime. Apparently, Robert had told Ranger that he and Jim had gained access to the Zantop's home by pretending they were conducting an environmental survey for a school project. They'd already tried this ruse sometime earlier on another intended victim in Rochester, Vermont, but he had turned them away.
该成员立即被游骑兵的爆料所震惊。确实，赞托普住所唯一丢失的物品是霍夫的钱包，而这一信息一直对公众保密。他们安排了与游骑兵的会面，他在会上分享了更多关于犯罪的见解。显然，罗伯特告诉游骑兵，他和吉姆通过假装正在为学校项目进行环境调查而进入了赞托普家。他们之前曾在佛蒙特州罗切斯特（Rochester）的另一名预定受害者身上尝试过这种诡计，但他把他们拒之门外。
Hoff Zantop, however, was a geologist and Earth-Sombertson. professor, so the topic was right up his alley. He'd welcomed the two young men into his home and taken them to his study to chat, while Susanna prepared lunch in the kitchen. Ranger also elaborated on the motive. As well as wanting to practice killing someone, Robert and Jim had wanted money. That's why they'd chosen a neighborhood near Dartmouth, which was wealthy and home to people who were relaxed about home security. But after they had murdered the Xantops, they panicked and left the house without taking anything other than Hoff's wallet.
然而，霍夫·赞托普是一位地质学家和地球科学教授，所以这个话题正合他的胃口。他欢迎这两个年轻人进入他的家，并带他们到书房聊天，而苏珊娜则在厨房准备午餐。游骑兵还详细说明了动机。除了想练习杀人之外，罗伯特和吉姆还想要钱。这就是为什么他们选择了达特茅斯附近的一个社区，那里很富裕，住着对家庭安全比较放松的人。但在谋杀赞托普夫妇后，他们惊慌失措，离开房子时除了霍夫的钱包外什么也没拿。
Ranger had asked Robert whether the crime was his idea or Jim's. Robert said it was kind of mutual, but described the dynamic between the two friends as one where he called the shots and Jim went along. This matched what those who knew the teenagers had said about their relationship. Ranger also provided details about the crime scene that could have only come from someone with firsthand knowledge of it. Rangers Inside gave investigators the closure they needed regarding a motive, and they finally stopped trying to find a link between the killers and their victims.
游骑兵曾问罗伯特，这起罪行是他的主意还是吉姆的主意。罗伯特说这算是共同的，但描述两个朋友之间的动态时说，他说了算，而吉姆则随声附和。这与那些了解这些少年的人对他们关系的描述相符。游骑兵还提供了只有亲身经历过的人才能知道的犯罪现场细节。游骑兵提供的内部信息让调查人员在动机方面得到了他们需要的结论，他们终于停止了试图寻找杀手与受害者之间联系的努力。
Robert Tulloch was old enough to be charged as an adult under New Hampshire state law, but Jim Parker, who was 16 at the time of the murders, was a juvenile. Nevertheless, the severity of the crime led to prosecutors charging him, as an adult as well. Jim's attorneys pushed back against this and the matter went to court. Ultimately, the prosecution won out. Following this, Jim Parker's defense team wanted to make a plea deal. In early December 2001, Jim Parker agreed to plead guilty to being an accomplice to second-degree murder. He would be sentenced to 25 years to life. State law would allow him to later apply for a sentence reduction, meaning he may only have to serve a minimum of 16 years and eight months.
罗伯特·塔洛赫已达到新罕布什尔州法律规定的成年人受审年龄，但谋杀时16岁的吉姆·帕克是未成年人。尽管如此，犯罪的严重性导致检察官也将他作为成年人起诉。吉姆的律师对此进行了反驳，此事闹上了法庭。最终，检方胜诉。此后，吉姆·帕克的辩护团队希望达成认罪协议。2001年12月初，吉姆·帕克同意承认二级谋杀罪的从犯。他将被判处25年至终身监禁。州法律允许他以后申请减刑，这意味着他可能只需服刑至少16年零8个月。
In exchange, he agreed to testify against Robert Tulloch at trial and tell investigators everything they wanted to know. Jim Parker spent five hours giving a detailed confession. Over time, his and Robert's friendship had become increasingly insular. The two teenagers felt a sense of superiority over everyone else, believing themselves. much smarter than their peers. In a school paper, Robert described himself as having a divine intellect. In one of his class papers, Jim wrote that if he had to have a letter burnt onto his chest, it would be the letter I for Incredible.
作为交换，他同意在审判中出庭指证罗伯特·塔洛赫，并告诉调查人员他们想知道的一切。吉姆·帕克花了五个小时给出了详细的供词。随着时间的推移，他和罗伯特的友谊变得越来越封闭。这两个少年对其他人有一种优越感，认为自己比同龄人聪明得多。在一篇学校论文中，罗伯特形容自己拥有“神圣的智力”。在其中一篇课堂论文中，吉姆写道，如果他必须在胸口烙上一个字母，那将是代表“不可思议”（Incredible）的字母I。
The boys dreamt of escaping Vermont, but they weren't satisfied by the thought of leaving for college. Robert thought higher education was a waste of time and led to a boring life of conformity and nine to five careers. He and Jim wanted to go further afield. They talked about travelling to Italy or France before settling on Australia. Australia was appealing because the people there spoke English, but it still seemed exotic to them. There were also lots of outdoorsy things for them to do and a variety of climates to explore. Gradually, their conversations about travel evolved into actual plans. They speculated about how much money they would need to live overseas and came up with a budget. They thought that $10,000 would be enough to cover their plane tickets and to support them
男孩们梦想着逃离佛蒙特州，但他们并不满足于去上大学的想法。罗伯特认为高等教育是在浪费时间，会导致枯燥的循规蹈矩的生活和朝九晚五的职业。他和吉姆想去更远的地方。他们谈论过去意大利或法国旅行，然后决定去澳大利亚。澳大利亚很有吸引力，因为那里的人说英语，但对他们来说仍然显得很异国情调。那里还有很多户外活动可以做，还有各种气候可以探索。渐渐地，他们关于旅行的谈话演变成了实际的计划。他们推测在海外生活需要多少钱，并制定了预算。他们认为1万美元足以支付他们的机票并支持他们
for one year. Robert began trying to think of easy ways they could raise the cash quickly. All of the ideas he came up with involved criminal activity. They began stealing mail in search of credit cards but gave up after 15 attempts with no results. Robert suggested they steal ATM machines or rob a bank. The plans evolved to the point where the friends visited some banks together to suss them out, but they abandoned the idea. Robert and Jim continued to dabble with criminal activity. They discussed carjacking a vehicle and robbing its occupants.
生活一年。罗伯特开始思考他们可以快速筹集现金的简单方法。他想出的所有主意都涉及犯罪活动。他们开始偷邮件寻找信用卡，但在尝试了15次没有结果后放弃了。罗伯特建议他们偷自动取款机或抢劫银行。计划发展到朋友们一起去一些银行踩点的地步，但他们放弃了这个想法。罗伯特和吉姆继续尝试犯罪活动。他们讨论了劫持车辆并抢劫车内乘客。
After talking about stealing a car to go for a joyride for some time, Robert gradually convinced Jim to give it a go. The pair came across a truck at a quarry they liked to drive to sometimes, which was unattended with its key in the ignition. The pair drove it around for a bit before leaving it at the quarry and going back home. They returned to the quarry another day to do the same thing, but this time a quarry worker found them. Jim managed to jump out and hide without being seen, but Robert, who was behind the wheel, got caught. The police gave him a verbal. warning, but that was it.
在谈论偷车去兜风一段时间后，罗伯特逐渐说服吉姆试一试。两人在他们有时喜欢开车去的采石场发现了一辆无人看管且钥匙插在点火开关上的卡车。两人开着它转了一会儿，然后把它留在采石场回家了。他们改天又回到采石场做同样的事情，但这次被一名采石场工人发现了。吉姆设法跳出来躲了起来，没有被看到，但坐在驾驶座上的罗伯特被抓住了。警察给了他口头警告，但仅此而已。
In late May 2000, they stole an all-terrain vehicle that was parked at a residence, then hid it in some woods near Jim's house, and listed it for sale on the online commerce site eBay. But no one wanted to buy it without registration papers. Months passed and the teenagers made no progress in their plans. Robert began to grow frustrated. One day, while driving around with the gym, he suggested they break into a house and steal something.
2000年5月下旬，他们偷了一辆停在住宅处的全地形车，然后把它藏在吉姆家附近的一些树林里，并在在线商业网站eBay上挂牌出售。但没有注册文件，没人愿意买。几个月过去了，少年们的计划没有任何进展。罗伯特开始感到沮丧。有一天，在和吉姆开车兜风时，他建议他们闯入一所房子偷点东西。
They had entered other people's homes without permission before. On the two occasions, they'd gone into the residences of school friends with other boys. As they drove through the streets looking for a place to break into, they spotted an elderly couple. Robert suggested they robbed the couple, saying they could use rocks to bash their heads, and then we'd take their money and run. Jim said no, telling Robert they'd get caught. But the seed was planted, and Robert began to talk more often about how easier it would be to rob people, then kill them to prevent being identified.
他们以前曾未经许可进入过别人的家。那两次，他们是和其他男孩一起进入学校朋友的住所的。当他们开车穿过街道寻找闯入的地方时，他们发现了一对老夫妇。罗伯特建议抢劫这对夫妇，说他们可以用石头砸他们的头，然后拿走他们的钱逃跑。吉姆拒绝了，告诉罗伯特他们会被抓住。但种子已经种下，罗伯特开始更频繁地谈论抢劫人们，然后杀死他们以防止被认出是多么容易。
Over several weeks, he talked to Jim into the plan. At first, the idea was to attack people out on the street, but eventually they decided it would be safer to target them at home. That way, no one else would see them. They would talk their way into a house by claiming their car had broken down and they needed to use a phone. Then they would tie up with the residents. They would steal their ATM and credit cards before killing them and dumping their bodies in a pre-dug grave. Because neither of them had ever been violent towards anyone before, Robert said they should practice taking a life.
在几周的时间里，他说服吉姆接受了这个计划。起初，想法是袭击街上的人，但最终他们决定在家里针对他们会更安全。这样，就不会有其他人看到他们。他们会声称车坏了需要用电话，以此骗进房子。然后他们会绑住居民。他们会偷走他们的自动取款机和信用卡，然后杀死他们，把尸体扔进预先挖好的坟墓里。因为他们两人以前从未对任何人使用过暴力，罗伯特说他们应该练习杀人。
He suggested he kill his pet dog, Ruby. Robert thought Ruby was stupid and Jim had seen him hit her before. But he rejected Robert's idea, believing they should only kill for financial gain and not take an innocent animal's life for the sake of it. Finally, on the evening of Wednesday, July 19, 2000, Robert and Jim decided they were ready to try out their plan. They went to an abandoned house outside of town that they liked to hang out at sometimes, and dug a large grave. They changed into commando clothing they had purchased from army surplus stores
他建议杀死他的宠物狗鲁比（Ruby）。罗伯特认为鲁比很蠢，吉姆以前见过他打它。但他拒绝了罗伯特的想法，认为他们应该只为经济利益而杀人，而不是为了杀而杀掉一只无辜的动物。最终，在2000年7月19日星期三晚上，罗伯特和吉姆决定他们准备好尝试他们的计划了。他们去了城外一所他们有时喜欢待的废弃房子，挖了一个大坟墓。他们换上了从军队剩余物资商店购买的突击队服装，
and slid knives into their boots. They also packed a backpack with duct tape and rope. Then they headed to a house just down the road. It was a holiday house that belonged to a couple from New York, so it was often empty. But on this particular night, the owner Andrew was staying there with their young son. Robert and Jim arrived at the house just after 10pm. Robert used a wire cutter to cut the home's phone lines while Jim hid in some bushes wearing a ski mask.
并将刀滑入靴子中。他们还装了一个装有管道胶带和绳子的背包。然后他们前往路边的一所房子。那是一对来自纽约的夫妇的度假屋，所以经常空着。但在那个特定的夜晚，主人安德鲁（Andrew）正带着他们年幼的儿子住在那里。罗伯特和吉姆在晚上10点刚过到达房子。罗伯特用钢丝钳剪断了房子的电话线，而吉姆戴着滑雪面罩躲在灌木丛中。
Then Robert knocked loudly and urgently on the front door. Andrew's face appeared at a window next to the door and he asked what Robert wanted. I have car trouble. Can you help me out? Robert replied. Andrew was suspicious and told Robert no. Robert asked if he had jumper cables and repeatedly pleaded to be let in to use the phone. Andrew refused, certain that the tall teenager was up to no good. When Robert continued to stand there, Andrew brought his right hand out from behind his back. He was holding a 9mm Glock pistol that he always carried with him.
然后罗伯特用力且急促地敲前门。安德鲁的脸出现在门旁的一扇窗户上，他问罗伯特想要什么。“我的车出了点问题。你能帮帮我吗？”罗伯特回答。安德鲁很怀疑，告诉罗伯特不行。罗伯特问他是否有跨接电缆，并反复恳求让他进去用电话。安德鲁拒绝了，确信这个高个子少年没安好心。当罗伯特继续站在那里时，安德鲁从背后伸出右手。他手里拿着一把他随身携带的9毫米格洛克（Glock）手枪。
At the sight of the gun, Robert stated, Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, I just wanted to use your phone. But he didn't seem scared and didn't leave. Andrew said he would call a local garage for him. Robert enthusiastically encouraged him to do so right away. Andrew went to dial the number and found the phone was dead. Realising that the teenager outside must have cut the wires, Andrew suspected that now he would be lying in wait for Andrew to go outside and check the phone line.
看到枪，罗伯特说：“哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，哇，我只是想用一下你的电话。”但他似乎并不害怕，也没有离开。安德鲁说他会为他打电话给当地的车库。罗伯特热情地鼓励他马上这样做。安德鲁去拨号码，发现电话没声音。意识到外面的少年一定剪断了电线，安德鲁怀疑他现在会守株待兔，等着安德鲁出去检查电话线。
Instead, Andrew sat low on the living room floor with his son and his pistol, on high alert for any noise indicating that Robert might be breaking in. But none ever came. After Andrew had made it clear that he was armed and had no intention of letting Robert in, Robert and Jim gave up on their plan that night. But they weren't deterred in the long term. A few months went by, and Robert continued to plot. By January of 2001, they felt ready to try again.
相反，安德鲁和儿子带着手枪坐在客厅地板上，高度警惕任何表明罗伯特可能闯入的噪音。但什么也没发生。在安德鲁明确表示他有武装且无意让罗伯特进入后，罗伯特和吉姆当晚放弃了计划。但他们并没有从长远上被吓倒。几个月过去了，罗伯特继续策划。到2001年1月，他们觉得准备好再次尝试了。
On New Year's Day, they placed an online order for two SOG seal 2000 combat knives. They also came up with an alternative ruse. Instead of one pretending their car had broken down while the other hit in the bushes, they would knock on the front door together during broad daylight. They'd say they were conducting an environmental survey for a school project, figuring people would be less spooked by clean-cut high school students in the middle of the day. On Saturday, January 20, 2001, Jim Parker borrowed his mother's green Subaru, then he and Robert drove to a nice neighbourhood in Granville, Vermont.
元旦那天，他们在网上订购了两把SOG Seal 2000战斗刀。他们还想出了一个替代的诡计。不再是一个人假装车坏了，另一个人躲在灌木丛中，他们会一起在光天化日之下敲前门。他们会说他们正在为学校项目进行环境调查，认为人们在白天被衣着整洁的高中生吓到的可能性较小。2001年1月20日星期六，吉姆·帕克借了他母亲的绿色斯巴鲁，然后他和罗伯特开车去了佛蒙特州格兰维尔（Granville）的一个好社区。
They chose the biggest house on a street called, North Hollow Road, which sat at the top of a hill. They went up to the front door and knocked. It was answered by an older man. The teenagers asked if they could interview him for an environmental survey. The man abruptly refused, saying he was too busy and shut the door. Robert and Jim were frustrated by yet another failure, but they refused to give up. They decided they'd try again, but next time they'd target a whole new area. Hanover, New Hampshire, was only a 40-minute drive from Chelsea and was home to wealthy people who might fall for their story. Also, they had no connection to the area, and as they lived in the next date over,
他们选择了北空心路（North Hollow Road）上一座位于山顶的最大的房子。他们走到前门敲门。一位老人开了门。少年们问是否可以采访他进行环境调查。那人断然拒绝，说他太忙了，并关上了门。罗伯特和吉姆对又一次失败感到沮丧，但他们拒绝放弃。他们决定再试一次，但下次他们会针对一个全新的区域。新罕布什尔州的汉诺威（Hanover）距离切尔西只有40分钟的车程，住着可能会相信他们故事的富人。此外，他们与该地区没有任何联系，而且由于他们住在隔壁州，
there would be nothing to tie them to the crime. A week later on Saturday, January 27, Robert and Jim set out again. After they arrived on Leafy Trescrow, Scott Road, just outside of Hanover, they tried one house, but no one was home. So they decided to try the next door neighbours. Hoff Zantop had opened the door to his home and was very friendly. He seemed interested in their survey and invited the teenagers inside, taking them to his study. Robert began asking questions while Jim pretended to take notes. They hadn't prepared a proper survey, so most of Robert's questions were made up on the spot, but Hoff was patient and helpful. About ten minutes into their conversation, Jim Parker was struck by how nice Hoff was and began to
没有任何东西能将他们与犯罪联系起来。一周后的1月27日星期六，罗伯特和吉姆再次出发。在到达汉诺威郊外绿树成荫的特雷斯科特路（Trescott Road）后，他们尝试了一所房子，但没人。所以他们决定尝试隔壁的邻居。霍夫·赞托普打开了家门，非常友好。他似乎对他们的调查很感兴趣，并邀请少年们进去，带他们去了书房。罗伯特开始提问，而吉姆假装做笔记。他们没有准备正式的调查，所以罗伯特的大部分问题都是当场编造的，但霍夫很有耐心且乐于助人。谈话进行了大约十分钟，吉姆·帕克被霍夫的友善所打动，开始
rethink their plan. As Robert wrapped up the interview, Hoff offered him some constructive criticism, saying, you need to be more prepared. He offered to put them in touch with a friend who might be able to help them improve their survey, and when he turned to his desk to look for the phone number, Robert struck. He pulled out one of the knives they'd brought, and when Hoff turned around, he stabbed him in the chest. Hoff screamed and fell to the floor, where Robert continued to stab him. Hoff's wife, Susanna, came running in from the kitchen. When she saw Robert lying on top of her husband stabbing him, she began screaming too and tried to grab at Robert. Jim grabbed Susanna and pulled her away, telling her to shut up. Then Robert told Jim to slit
重新考虑他们的计划。当罗伯特结束采访时，霍夫给了他一些建设性的批评，说：“你们需要准备得更充分一些。”他主动提出帮他们联系一位可能帮助他们改进调查的朋友，当他转身去书桌找电话号码时，罗伯特动手了。他拔出他们带来的其中一把刀，当霍夫转身时，他刺向了他的胸口。霍夫尖叫着倒在地上，罗伯特继续刺他。霍夫的妻子苏珊娜从厨房跑了进来。当她看到罗伯特压在她丈夫身上刺他时，她也开始尖叫，并试图抓住罗伯特。吉姆抓住苏珊娜把她拉开，叫她闭嘴。然后罗伯特叫吉姆割开
Susanna's throat, and he did. During the frenzied attack, Robert sustained a deep cut to one leg. The teenagers hadn't remembered to threaten their victims into handing over the pins for their debit cards, but there was $340 cash in Hoff's wallet. which they stole. In the rush to leave the house, they left their knife sheaths behind. On the drive home, they realized their mistake. Later that evening, they decided to go back for the sheaths, but when they drove past the Xanthops house,
苏珊娜的喉咙，他照做了。在疯狂的袭击中，罗伯特的一条腿受了深伤。少年们没记住要威胁受害者交出借记卡的密码，但霍夫的钱包里有340美元现金，他们偷走了。在匆忙离开房子时，他们留下了刀鞘。在回家的路上，他们意识到了自己的错误。那天晚上晚些时候，他们决定回去拿刀鞘，但当他们开车经过赞托普家时，
they saw police cruisers parked outside. After all their plotting to commit the perfect crime, the error of leaving the knife sheaths behind led detectives to Jim Parker and Robert Tulloch within three weeks. It has been speculated that Hoff Zantop's constructive criticism of Robert Tulloch was what led to Robert abruptly and violently attacking him. The plan had been to tie up their victims to obtain bank details, but Robert seemingly became angry after being told he needed to be better prepared.
他们看到警车停在外面。在他们策划实施完美犯罪之后，留下刀鞘的错误在三周内将侦探引向了吉姆·帕克和罗伯特·塔洛赫。据推测，霍夫·赞托普对罗伯特·塔洛赫的建设性批评是导致罗伯特突然暴力袭击他的原因。计划本是绑住受害者以获取银行详细信息，但罗伯特在被告知需要准备得更好后似乎变得愤怒。
Those who knew him have described other incidents in his life where he lashed out aggressively out of wounded pride. Most of the money stolen from the Xantops was spent during their two failed attempts to go on the run. While Jim Parker agreed to a plea deal, Robert Tulloch's attorneys were preparing to argue he was not guilty by reason of insanity. A psychiatrist hired by Robert's defense diagnosed him with bipolar disorder, and the defense said he'd been in the middle of an extreme manic episode that turned into psychosis at the time of the murders. Robert's family were opposed to this strategy, as it would require them to testify in extreme detail about private family matters. There was huge public interest in the case, and the trial was going to be a media circus. Those who knew Robert were also doubtful about his diagnosis,
那些了解他的人描述了他生活中其他因自尊心受损而猛烈抨击的事件。从赞托普夫妇那里偷来的大部分钱都在他们两次失败的逃亡尝试中花光了。虽然吉姆·帕克同意了认罪协议，但罗伯特·塔洛赫的律师准备辩称他因精神错乱而无罪。罗伯特的辩护律师聘请的一位精神科医生诊断他患有双相情感障碍，辩护方称他在谋杀时正处于转变为精神病的极端躁狂发作中。罗伯特的家人反对这一策略，因为它需要他们极其详细地作证关于家庭私事。此案引起了巨大的公众关注，审判将成为媒体马戏团。那些了解罗伯特的人也对他的诊断表示怀疑，
saying that he'd never displayed any signs of manic episodes, let alone psychosis. After Robert found out Jim would testify against him, he realized he was unlikely to win his case. On Friday, April 5, 2002, he pleaded guilty to two counts of first-degree murder and was sentenced to life without the possibility of parole. In their victim impact statement, Veronica and Mariana Zantop reflected on how tragic it was that their parents' generous natures and love of teaching had been taken advantage of by their killers. Veronica stated, quote,
说他从未表现出任何躁狂发作的迹象，更不用说精神病了。在罗伯特发现吉姆会出庭指证他后，他意识到自己不太可能赢得官司。2002年4月5日星期五，他承认犯有两项一级谋杀罪，被判处终身监禁，不得假释。在受害者影响陈述中，维罗妮卡（Veronica）和玛丽安娜·赞托普（Mariana Zantop）反思了父母慷慨的天性和对教学的热爱被杀手利用是多么悲惨。维罗妮卡说，引用：
My father's name was Hoff, which in his name was Hoff, which in his life. German means to help. My father lived up to his name. That their desire to help, to teach, and to open their home to perfect strangers was abused in such a horrific way, makes their deaths seem like the greatest violation. Rather than focus on the inhumanity and monstrosity and the sheer stupidity of their brutal and senseless deaths, I've tried to console myself by trying to perpetuate the essence of my parents. two people with true open-heartedness and generosity who fought for positive change. And my sister and I will continue that fight.
“我父亲的名字叫霍夫，在他的名字里，霍夫在德语中意味着‘帮助’。我父亲不负他的名字。他们想要帮助、教导并向完全陌生的人敞开家门的愿望被如此可怕地滥用，使他们的死亡看起来像是最大的侵犯。与其关注他们残酷和毫无意义的死亡的不人道、怪诞和纯粹的愚蠢，我试图通过努力延续我父母的本质来安慰自己。两个拥有真正开放的心和慷慨的人，为积极的变革而奋斗。我和我妹妹将继续这场斗争。”
As Robert Tulloch listened to this statement, he stared directly at both women with a blank expression. Later that afternoon, Veronica and Mariana read the statement again at Jim Parker's sentencing. Unlike his friend, Jim rocked back and forth and began to cry as he listened. He subsequently asked permission to speak. It took him almost a minute before he managed to get out the words, I'm sorry, there's not much more I can say than that. Jim Parker and Robert Tulloch were initially sent to different prisons,
当罗伯特·塔洛赫听着这份声明时，他面无表情地直视着这两个女人。那天下午晚些时候，维罗妮卡和玛丽安娜在吉姆·帕克的量刑听证会上再次宣读了这份声明。与他的朋友不同，吉姆在听的时候前后摇晃并开始哭泣。他随后请求发言。他花了近一分钟才说出这些话：“我很抱歉，除了这些我没法再说更多了。”吉姆·帕克和罗伯特·塔洛赫最初被送往不同的监狱，
but later both began to serve at the New Hampshire State Prison for Men. They were held in different areas of the facility and not permitted contact with one another. In 2012, the United States Supreme Court ruled that it was unconstitutional to sentence offenders who committed crimes as juveniles to life imprisonment without parole. Consequently, Robert Tulloch became one of five inmates in the state of New Hampshire who was eligible for resentencing. His resentencing hearing is scheduled to take place in July of 2024. In April of 2024, James Parker was granted parole. Veronica Zantop spoke with the Valley News about the development, stating that while she misses her parents deeply, she isn't motivated by revenge against their killers.
但后来两人都开始在新罕布什尔州男子州立监狱服刑。他们被关在设施的不同区域，不允许相互接触。2012年，美国最高法院裁定，对未成年时犯罪的罪犯判处终身监禁且不得假释是违宪的。因此，罗伯特·塔洛赫成为新罕布什尔州五名有资格重新量刑的囚犯之一。他的重新量刑听证会定于2024年7月举行。2024年4月，詹姆斯·帕克获得假释。维罗妮卡·赞托普在接受《山谷新闻》（Valley News）采访时谈到了这一进展，称虽然她深深地怀念父母，但她并没有被对杀手的复仇所驱使。
Quote, since it happened, I've become a mother, I've become a psychiatrist, and I realized that the world is complex and teenagers are complex. And maybe some of the thoughts I had at the time have changed in terms of compassion for his family and even him at age 16. doing something terrible. Veronica said that neither she nor her sister felt it was their place to decide whether James Parker should receive parole. They had already acknowledged the trauma his crime had created and felt that maybe he should have the chance to make something of his life, adding, I wish James's family the best and hope that they are able to heal. The legacy left by Hoff and Susanna Zantop lives on at the Dartmouth College. Every year, the university holds a comparative literature lecture in Susanna's honour.
引用说，自从那件事发生后，我成为了一名母亲，也成为了一名精神科医生，我意识到这个世界很复杂，青少年也很复杂。也许我当时的一些想法已经改变了，我对他的家人，甚至是对16岁时做出可怕事情的他，产生了一些同情。维罗妮卡说，她和她的妹妹都觉得，决定詹姆斯·帕克是否应该获得假释不是她们的事。她们已经承认了他的罪行所造成的创伤，并觉得也许他应该有机会去成就自己的人生，并补充道，我祝愿詹姆斯的家人一切顺利，希望他们能够治愈。霍夫和苏珊娜·赞托普留下的遗产在达特茅斯学院延续着。每年，学校都会举办一场以苏珊娜命名的比较文学讲座。
A garden named for the couple was also planted near the heart of the campus, between a school chapel and a hall. It features trees, ferns and perennial flowers, and was designed as a place where students and staff could go for contemplation and remembrance. It lives as a permanent reminder of Hoff and Susanna Zantop's passion for justice, learning and community. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在校园中心，学校礼拜堂和大厅之间，还种植了一个以这对夫妇名字命名的花园。花园里种满了树木、蕨类植物和多年生花卉，旨在为学生和教职员工提供一个沉思和缅怀的地方。它作为霍夫和苏珊娜·赞托普对正义、学习和社区热情的永久纪念而存在。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。